So, let's use these TimeUtils
tools to create simple movement.
Just a ball moving around in a circle.
The first thing we need to do, is set
up some constants that determine what
the movement of the ball looks like,
including how many
seconds the ball should take to
go all the way through one cycle.
Then we need to store the time at which
the application adapter was created
by declaring a long called initialTime.
And then setting equal
it to TimeUtils.nanoTime
in the create callback.
Now, down in the renderer callback,
we can figure out how long it's
been since the game started running
by subtracting the initial time from
the current value of TimeUtils.nanoTime.
This gives the number of nanoseconds
that the game has been running.
But seconds would be
a lot more convenient.
LibGDX provides a very nice
MathUtils.nanoToSec constant
to help with that conversion.
Now we need to figure out
where in the cycle we're at.
If we take the elapsedSeconds and
divide it by the period,
we get the number of elapsed periods
since the game started running.
We can then take the modulis
with 1 to determine what
fractional part of a cycle has elapsed.
So we now have a number that counts up
from 0 to 1 and then resets back to 0.
And we need to map that interval
to a position on a circle.
Don't suppose you remember
the parametric equation on a circle?
You can check out the link
in the instructor notes for
a short refresher on some trigonometry.
To figure out the x
position of our ball,
we take the center point of the world,
and then we add the movement radius
times the cosine of the cycle
position times two Pi.
For the y position
it's almost identical,
except we're taking the sine
instead of the cosine.
And there we go,
we've achieved circular movement.
Even with something so
simple as balls moving in circles,
we can make some surprisingly
beautiful patterns.
Check out what we can do with 20 balls,
each moving at a different
harmonic speed.
[MUSIC]